everything is changed because of YouTube  basically I'm going to be doing one of  these things every single day  hello this supposed out is okay is your  good cuz i wanted that ones will be on  camera i love you and i'm bout to drop  this new video like a mixtape we saw  this tremendous potential that youtube  had as a community building tool people  click on it and then they start watching  and they're like they're hooked there's  a tumor in your head we had a  responsibility to these people who had  become our family i have to continue  blogging how am I getting so emotional  over to people that i watch on the  internet  a huge thing in my life this one broke  my heart  I can save one person mission  accomplished realness of it was what  made our community grow  it's magic it's really just like magic  because of content like this if life is  worth living than it's worth recording  speed  you